خلف شريط الشرطة ، هذا
السوق المزدحم عادة في مدينة ووهان بوسط الصين
يجلس مقفرًا بشكل مخيف ، وهذا هو نقطة
الصفر للمرض الذي يثير
قلقًا عالميًا ، لذلك هذا هو المكان الذي
تعتقد السلطات أن مصدر
فيروس كورونا هو سوق الحياة البرية
والمأكولات البحرية ويمكنك  ربما
ترى هناك ، لقد تم تطويقه ، لديك
شرطة في جميع الزوايا ، من
الحساس جدًا أنه في غضون دقائق من
وصولنا وتسجيل الأمن طلب
منا التوقف عن التصوير ، كان هناك شعور بعدم الارتياح في
جميع أنحاء من عانينا من هان
بمجرد صعودنا إلى الطائرة  القطار
من بكين ، كل سيارة تقريبًا ممتلئة ، معظم
الوجوه مغطاة تقريبًا كل شخص
يسافر إلى المنزل للفحص الصارم للسنة القمرية الجديدة
عند وصوله واحدًا تلو الآخر من
خلال فحص مقياس الحرارة ،
تأكد من عدم إحضار
حمى معهم
يبدو أن هذه الطائرة تغادر
مراكز النقل في جميع أنحاء الصين ،
كان الفيروس ينتشر بشكل أساسي من خلال
انتقال الجهاز التنفسي ومن المرجح
أن يتحور وهو ما سيحدث  زيادة خطر
انتشار الوباء بالإضافة إلى أن
اندفاع السفر في عيد الربيع شهد
هجرة جماعية للناس مما
زاد بشكل موضوعي من خطر
انتشار الأوبئة والصعوبات
في اتخاذ
تدابير وقائية ومراقبة فعالة يجب أن نكون دائمًا في
حالة تأهب قصوى وألا نتخذ هذا أبدًا  ورائي قليلاً ،
هذه واحدة من المستشفيات القليلة
هنا في المنطقة المكرسة
لعلاج بعض أولئك الذين هم إما
حالات مؤكدة أو حالات مشتبه بإصابتها
بفيروس كورونا أمامك ، لديك عدد
قليل من الموظفين الذين لاحظنا أنهم جميعًا
يرتدون أقنعة  حتى أن بعضهم
يرتدي قفازات واقية فقط
لمنع أي تعرض محتمل ، فقد
تسبب في مزاج الأعياد المعتاد
وتوقف ووهان ، وقد
أوقف عمل البائعين هذا العام ، حيث أصبح
وضع الالتهاب الرئوي خطيرًا ،
لذا لم يأت الكثير من الناس
هنا لشراء سلع إنها من
مدينة تبعد حوالي ساعتين بالسيارة عن ووهان
، لقد حصلت على أقنعة بالقرب منها
وتعترف بأنها  تشعر بالقلق وكذلك
ابنتها والأقارب الآخرون
الذين كانوا يطلبون مني العودة إلى المنزل ولكن
لا يمكنني المغادرة بكل مخزوني هنا
، لقد اشتريت هذه السلع بالفعل
وليس لدي خيار ولا بد لي من البقاء هنا
والاستقالة بنفسي  لمقدري البائعون الآخرون
يأملون أكثر أن تخبرني هذه المرأة أنها
لا تشعر بالحاجة إلى ارتداء قناع ،
ربما لدي نظرة إيجابية ،
لقد كنت أتحقق من التعليمات عبر الإنترنت
على بايدو مثل شرب المزيد من الماء أو
غسل يديك بشكل متكرر
أعتقد أنه ينبغي  كن على ما يرام ، المجهول الذي
يلوح في الأفق فوق مدينة مع ارتفاع
عدد القتلى غير واضح ما هو التالي بالنسبة لووهان
والأحد عشر مليون شخص الذين يسمونها
الوطن
جيدًا ، فقد خضعنا لبعض تلك
الفحوصات الصحية لأننا كما ذكرت ،
كنا من بين الركاب الذين غادروا
ووهان إلى  عد إلى بكين قبل بضع
ساعات فقط حقًا وكنا من بين
آخر القطارات التي غادرت قبل أن يبدأ هذا
الإغلاق في مكانه الآن ، إنه أمر
أساسي جدًا فيما يتعلق بالشكل الذي يبدو عليه الفحص.
أعني بمجرد
أن نزلنا من القطار هنا ، واحدًا تلو
الآخر ، سيضعون مقياس حرارة على
رؤوسنا ويتحققون لمعرفة ما إذا
كنا مصابين بالحمى أم لا ، ثم دعنا
نواصل السير على هذا ما نراه
يمكنني أيضًا  أخبرك أثناء
المرور بالأمن للوصول إلى القطار الذي
يغادر ووهان ، لاحظنا أن لديهم نوعًا
من إعداد النظام حيث كان لديهم
شاشات وكانوا يقومون
بأجهزة كشف حرارية وقالوا إنهم كانوا يبحثون
دون أن يدرك الناس ذلك في تلك
اللحظة  وجميع الأشخاص الذين هم الآن
موظفين في تلك المحطات
وحتى الشرطة والقوات شبه العسكرية الموجودة
هناك يغطون وجوههم بشكل ملحوظ
أيضًا ووهان على وجه الخصوص
أصبح الآن إلزاميًا ارتداء قناع الوجه
ليس فقط لحماية نفسك ولكن
الآخرين  كانت الرحلة بالنسبة لنا
ممتعة ، أعني أنها كانت الساعة 3:00 صباحًا
للاستيقاظ الذي دفعنا حقًا إلى
إدراك أن هذه قد تكون آخر مرة
في عدد كبير من الأيام
يمكننا فيها مغادرة ووهان بسهولة تامة
ولذلك حجزنا قطارًا تمكنا من النزول
منه ، لكنني سأقول أيضًا مئات الأشخاص
الآخرين الذين كانوا معنا واستيقظوا
مبكرًا مع عائلاتهم الذين
جمعوا الأمتعة التي بحوزتهم
وصعدوا في طوابير طويلة في انتظار المحاولة
للحصول على تذكرة على متن القطار ومعظم
ما رأيناه كان قادرًا على القيام بذلك وكان قادرًا
على الصعود إليه كان أحد الأمثلة التي
برزت بالنسبة لي على الرغم من أننا كنا
نركب القطار ولاحظنا وجود زوجين
يقفان هناك وذهبا طوال
الطريق  إلى المنصة جون
ولم يصعدوا إلى القطار لكنهم كانوا يلوحون
لابنهم وجده
أرسلوا الاثنين إلى
بكين وسألت سي إن إن لماذا لم
تنضم إليهم وقالوا إنهم لم يفعلوا.
يريدون المخاطرة بتعريض أحبائهم الذين
يعيشون هنا لأية تهديدات محتملة
بحيث يخبرك هذا فقط بمدى الانقسام
حتى مع العائلات وهذا هو الوقت
الذي من المفترض أن تكون فيه العائلات
معًا إنه عيد الربيع
، السنة القمرية الجديدة وهكذا  انها
تسبب لبعض s
أفاد عالم
عينته الحكومة الآن أن
المسؤولين في الصين يتسابقون لاحتواء
فيروس ووهان التاجي من خلال زيادة
عدد مناطق فحص درجة الحرارة بالأشعة تحت الحمراء
في الأماكن العامة أثناء تفشي المرض.
انتشر إلى ما لا يقل عن خمس دول
بما في ذلك تايلاند واليابان وكوريا الجنوبية
والآن الولايات المتحدة  فيروسات كورونا هي مجموعة كبيرة
من الفيروسات الشائعة بين الحيوانات في
حالات نادرة يمكن أن تنتقل من
الحيوانات إلى البشر وفقًا للمراكز الأمريكية
لمكافحة الأمراض
والوقاية منها ، ويمكن للفيروسات أن تصيب الأشخاص
عادةً بمرض خفيف إلى متوسط في ال
هاز التنفسي العلوي مشابه لـ
تشمل أعراض البرد الشائعة
سيلان الأنف والسعال والتهاب الحلق وربما
صداع وربما حمى يمكن أن
تستمر لمدة يومين وهناك عدد
قليل من فيروسات كورونا البشرية
المعروف أنها مميتة
بما في ذلك متلازمة الشرق الأوسط التنفسية أو متلازمة الشرق الأوسط التنفسية
أو متلازمة الشرق الأوسط التنفسية والجهاز التنفسي الحاد.
المتلازمة المعروفة باسم
سارس في الوقت الحالي لا توجد لقاحات
للحماية من هذه العائلة من الفيروسات ،
لكن المعاهد الوطنية للصحة
في الولايات المتحدة تعمل على واحدة لمكافحة
فيروس كورونا ووهان في اللحظة الصحية الحالية
أنا ماندي جاثر